from axios I just want to say
that I gotta give a shout out to axios
for one-upping the New York Post in
their pun game Old Yeller Biden's
private Fury Bravo axio had to add a
little bit of insult to that so this
look at this picture of Joe Biden I
guess like it's like the dark Brandon
meme uh basically the gist of the story
is very very simple probably they're
they're arguing that privately Joe Biden
screaming at people insulting them
saying don't effing BS me get the F out
of here and that uh they claim that if
he doesn't yell at you in fact he
doesn't respect you here's what I
actually think and no one is safe said
one official
there's there one one view of this is
that they're putting this story out
there to make it seem like Joe Biden is
is spry because he's some kind of fire
because you're just gonna happen
a lot of regular people who don't watch
shows like this who don't watch clips of
Joe Biden are going to imagine him as
this like energetic guy being like hey
you tell me I'll tell you like they are
secondhand trying to convince us that
Joe Biden's a hard ass
I'm not going to buy it because I've
seen videos falling up the stairs but
this is what they're trying to do today
he got lost on stage and had to be quiet
it's not great I mean also it's giving
Trump on The Apprentice right like we
already have a strong leader in politics
there's someone else whose personality
you said was too too intense for this I
think what gets me about the Biden
family is if you're going to be corrupt
you have to secure your legacy for
maintaining influence when you can no
longer be in the public positions of
power right so like I don't know but
maybe the Clinton foundation for example
that would be a way to continue to have
influence after the fact but right now
with the bidens
I don't know of any kind of uh
non-profit that they successfully run
there's no Heir Apparent obviously
tragically Beau was uh apparently the
best kid and also passed away first and
then we have his daughter and we have
Hunter who neither one of them are going
to launch political campaigns soon so
it's not like the Bush family where
there was a son a couple of them coming
up to the ranks I mean if Joe Biden is
really in cognitive decline this is the
end of them so there is a reason the
grandkid right
they need as many things right seriously
especially she's from Middle America
she's from Arkansas but I was gonna say
there there's nowhere to go so why
wouldn't everyone bail out on them to
your point like they don't have any
loyalty loyalty to the power they have
loyalty to the money I'd even link this
story to to the hard drive and what I
mean by that is when I was doing a lot
of my early reporting on the hard drive
the people that I was working on it with
we would always sit around and joke you
know these are the stories that they're
eventually going to use to impeach Joe
Biden with right and if you saw the last
two weeks or or so there's definitely
been more media attention given to the
hunter Biden hard drive and what's going
on there and the people who are involved
even it cuts through the mainstream
media occasionally and I think that a
lot of this media war that we're seeing
Duke out is sort of between the
Democratic establishment like the DNC
and Joe Biden in terms of trying to
determine who the candidate is going to
be for 2024 and I think a lot of the
people who don't want Joe Biden to run
again are playing up the hard drive
stuff to try to take him out of the
running and I think this in some ways is
maybe the Biden Camp saying like no Joe
Biden is in control he's in he yells at
people my favorite by the way the best
part of the article if you read down the
bullet point where he's like he gets
really mad at all the Yale educated
staffers using acronyms I was like
that's it's so fake it's so it's so
feigns but I cannot remember the acronym
yeah maybe you don't use un yeah like
what what does that mean I have
forgotten
he's probably just sitting there going
huh what you oh they're just like oh
he's getting he's getting ornery again I
would get frustrated if I were
constantly confused too that that's not
fun this is the sad thing about Joe
Biden one of the uh signs of someone
suffering from dementia is anger
because what happens to the person when
they can't remember and there's and they
can't understand what's happening it's
frustrating for people it's you know
you're sitting here and people are
saying words you don't understand you
can't remember and you're getting angry
with yourself like why can't I remember
what they're talking about you just get
mad you just Outburst so this this
happens to a lot of older people when
they get frustrated with being unable to
do the situation because I mean for most
of our lives our wits are about us our
you know we can respond we can react
sometimes we don't know things it's fine
but imagine knowing you know it but you
can't recall it it's just so frustrating
to lose frustrating to lose that control
it's sad really
but I gotta say as sad as it may be like
a dude should not be president yeah it's
also this is just like uh I think it's a
derivation of his actual personality
which according to who's this uh Jeff
kanocton a former Biden campaign and
sent uh Senate Aid Chief of Staff to
Kaufman when he filled Biden's seat in
the Senate said that he was uh that
Biden was an ego Maine ewomaniac a lot
of crap determined to manage his staff
through fear this guy's got a reputation
of being a real nasty guy I mean there's
a video of him being like if they are
found within this much crack you will
serve five I don't know what is minimum
years in prison was that he didn't do to
Hunter with Hunter I like that video
because then someone cut it so that
there were clips of Hunter Biden in
between he's like you hear Joe Biden's
voice being like this is on you know
you'll go to jail I mean well it's like
his Hunter's home movies I don't know
I'm not driving crap you're doing crack
while driving yeah he's like smoking
you're like I feel like if only your
father could yeah but come on come on
hold on like could you imagine being
Hunter Biden and you're driving down the
street smoking cracking he's thinking
man life is good and the Porsche it's a
nice New Way takes a picture to make
sure he saves that memory but doesn't
that like speak to the complete
arrogance of this family that Hunter
Biden could drop his laptop off at a at
a just normal repair shop and think
nothing bad can happen to me I am too
important and too powerful oh I bet Joe
has said to Hunter and I don't know
probably I'll take care of whatever I
got it Hunter and Joe probably gets off
on that he's probably like I'm so
powerful I can I can protect the weak no
no I bet he loves it I bet I bet Joe I
bet Joe goes to Hunter and says You're a
worthless stupid little piece he
probably does that too but I'll take
care of it don't worry no he didn't say
that the abusive and then he says here
the only reason I'm taking care of it is
because I get the 10 cut and don't you
forget it you think absolutely when
there were those leaked messages where
it's like dad takes your salary or
whatever that was all about what is that
like Joe takes the salaries from his
kids or something he like controls their
lives allegedly and didn't this is
something that his daughter referenced
in her diary that got published right
like that their dad is controlling that
he controls their finances I thought it
was a text message from 100 it said
something I think there was 100 thing
and I'm saying there's also oh yeah this
thing would you mean that theoretically
both of his kids are confirming that
this is a controlled family which either
means that he does not think his adult
children can handle themselves or that
there is a very strange imbalance of
power in this family which might explain
again why there's nowhere for the Biden
family to go there's no one to take over
there's no clear Direction so when
though they have uh garnered a lot of
influence ultimately
people will bail out of the ship
yeah
that's one way to put it
uh yeah yeah when people turn on the
hated
um he uh there's one thing that we're
missing with Joe Biden is modern video
of him just being normal and talking
to people like in a regular environment
it's all curated speech crap like I
don't even know what his personality is
like to be honest I've never really seen
him chill and like have a long
conversation because he just plagiarizes
things yeah literally he dropped out of
the 1988 run for presidency because he
was plagiarizing got caught plagiarizing
man those are the days though you know
you could literally say whatever you
wanted because you couldn't fact check
anything because he's like what do you
mean there's no internet yeah and then
someone was like hey that's the exact
verbatim quote from this other guy he's
like oh I'm caught that's the funny
thing though what if mine was just like
no it's not
how are you gonna prove it the media
would be like oh well it turns out that
Joe Biden said at first time traveled
then this other guy ripped him off and
then Joe Biden went back in time like
but but today they would bend to his
will today we can play videos and prove
a thing is false back then it's just
like what Biden would say a thing the
media would be alike not true and he'd
go like ah you got me
why wouldn't you just be like to meet
there alone
no like that's my speech have a nice day
no one's gonna hear it I mean here's the
crazy like he didn't why did he drop out
of the race
I guess they had proof because they'll
play video of him talking with like
Robert F Kennedy talking and he's like
saying the same stuff
um I guess they had that technology it
was good he's doing that now I think
well I don't know no that was from 1988
but uh now they'll they'll still tell
you that they didn't say it right after
they said it and there's video proof
that they said this was running that
year I mean I think part of it might
just be that he didn't have the English
institutional uh prowess to stay in the
right no one was going to back him up
that could be I haven't looked into it
88 what was that Dukakis and George Bush
Senior I think I think it was Michael
Dukakis might be well it was that was
his that was a democratic I was two guy
so it was a boring time
I don't know I will study my U.S history
and get back I watch Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles that was by 1988
it was much better yes although that's
the thing man we were all like in that
you know snowed into that that Dome they
had us captured in that media Dome now
we're outside of it it's weird really
how the internet has been like one of
the best things ever and one of the
worst things ever at the same time yeah
it's created this group of people who
are able to understand a lot more than
we've ever understood and also a
psychotic death cult that sterilizes
kids so you know yeah there's that
trying to communicate with text I think
is so they'll look back and realize how
damaging was because we used to write
letters and mail them to each other but
it was like a last resort if you left a
note on your refrigerator for your
roommate it was passive aggressive and
nasty if you didn't go to your roommate
just talk to their face but now like
talk about passive aggressive text
conversations okay yeah and trying to
have a relation like what you think
people are gonna why is there like a 80
divorce rate or whatever 60 divorce rate
50 of people males under 30 haven't had
sex in the last year some crazy number
like
the stupid stupid misuse of the Internet
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time